joking aside I was doing a play many
years ago in New York and I came home
one night after the show and there was a
letter at my apartment building from the
Four Seasons Hotel and I read it and it
was one of those thoughtful articulate
letters I got about this whole play and
we signed Bruce Willis and I immediately
called my friend Stewart and said
you to wind up and he said I know what
you're talking about so I called Bruce I
said you really write me this letter he
said yeah so we had a beer and he says
essentially you're doing the kind of
work I want to be part of and whatever
you're doing if you can put me in the
mix I'm in sight unseen and I didn't
think that would really stick and many
years later when I wanted to make my own
film real passion project it's hard to
get those things done he was the first
person I called and he said I told you
if you ever need me I'm in and we just
made this movie together and had a
beautiful time and I wouldn't have
gotten it made without you and I'm
really deeply grateful for that I love
you or maybe I'm a very good actor and
I'm just acting when I say that you
would
you wouldn't know the difference and
that's the reason I love you
[Applause]
[Music]
you